die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
und das sind die Nachrichten Themen von
heute
Rückkehr der Schuldenbremse
Finanzminister Lindner verteidigt im
Bundestag seine Sparpläne
erst Brände jetzt extreme Fluten
Griechenland leidet unter einem Sommer
der extreme
[Applaus]
erfolgreicher Kraftakt Alexanders verit
erreicht in New York das Viertelfinale
der US Open
die Ferien im Bundestag sind zu Ende
seit heute wird der Haushalt fürs
kommende Jahr beraten der bringt bittere
Einsparungen zum Beispiel bei den
Freiwilligendiensten aber eben auch
weniger Schulden sagte Finanzminister
der Bundesrechnungshof rückt die
Regierung verschleiere die echte
Verschuldung ein Blick auf die Zahlen im
corona-krisenjahr 2021 waren die
Ausgaben auf einen Höhepunkt geschnellt
im kommenden Jahr sollen
445,7 Milliarden reichen neue Schulden
sind in Höhe von 16,6 Milliarden
eingeplant in diesem Jahr waren es noch
45,6 damit soll die im Grundgesetz
verankerte Schuldenbremse eingehalten
werden die neue Schulden nur sehr
begrenzt zulässt Daniel pontzen aus
Berlin
selbstironie ist manchmal auch in der
Politik ein gern eingesetztes Mittel
heute etwa scherzte der Finanzminister
wenn Kritik an seinem Haushalt von allen
Seiten komme scheine das Ergebnis
ausgewogener zu sein als wenn sich nur
eine Seite beschwere insgesamt aber
betonte Lindner die Notwendigkeit zu
Sparsamkeit zurückzufinden die
Schuldenstandsquote darf nicht von Krise
zu Krise weiter ansteigen
vererbt der arme Onkel Schulden kann man
das Erbe ausschlagen beim Bundeshaushalt
funktioniert das nicht und deshalb haben
wir auch eine moralische Verantwortung
gegenüber denjenigen die nach uns kommen
genau dieses
Verantwortungsbewusstsein viele aber
sagt die Union die diversen
Sondervermögen die der Rechnungshof
jüngst als sonderschulden monierte
zeigten dass Lindner sich mit seinen
sparvorsätzen in der Ampel nicht aber
durchsetzen können einzig und allein
ihre kleine Fraktion hier in der Mitte
hat ihn Applaus ge spendet was sie
vorgestellt haben Herr Minister ist ganz
offensichtlich nicht der Haushalts
Entwurf der Regierung sondern der
Haushaltsentwurf der FDP man hat fast
den Eindruck Christian allein zu Haus
Rückhalt aber gab es aus der Ampel auch
für den wenig harmonischen Weg hin zu
diesem Entwurf
da sitzen Bundesminister die um ihre
Themen Ringen die für ihre Themen
kämpfen und das erwarten wir auch von
Ihnen und das macht
Haushaltsverhandlungen vielleicht nicht
ganz so einfach die AFD kritisierte
ebenfalls das viele Ausgaben nicht aus
dem Kernhaushalt kommen
[Applaus]
sofort vorbei die Linke verweist auf aus
ihrer Sicht falsche und zu wenig
Investitionen sie wollen die
Schuldenbremse weiter anziehen das hat
mit wirtschaftlichen Sachverstand nichts
zu tun das verbaut unsere Zukunft das
darf nicht sein der Zukunft konkret dem
Zusammenhalt der Gesellschaft werde der
Haushalt sehr wohl dienen so die Grünen
von vielen Stellen schon wichtige
Antworten aber an manchen Stellen werden
wir im Parlament noch die gemeinsame
Antworten Ringen und auch gemeinsame
Arbeiten der heutigen Einbringung des
Haushalts Folgen Beratungen den
Bundestag und Bundesrat die finale
Verabschiedung ist für Dezember geplant
fragen wir Theo call in Berlin wie ist
dieser Kurs Lindners einzuschätzen wird
da tatsächlich gespart oder eher
verschleiert
es gilt wie so auf dem Leben beides vor
dem Schleier wird gespart und dahinter
liegen die Mehrausgaben der
Schattenhaushalte bis auf das
Verteidigungsministerium mussten ja alle
ressortseinsparungen vorlegen was unterm
Strich dazu geführt hat dass die
Neuverschuldung knapp innerhalb der
gesetzlichen Schuldenbremse bleibt wobei
angesichts der wirtschaftlichen Probleme
ja noch unklar ist wie die
Steuerschätzung im Herbst ausfallen wird
vor allem aber besagte Blick des
Bundesrechnungshofes hinter den Schleier
dass die tatsächliche Verschuldung des
Bundes fünfmal so hoch ist wie im Etat
ausgewiesen jedenfalls wenn man die
Gelder aus den Schattenhaushalten mit
einbezieht und das müsste man denn auch
die sind ja aufgenommene Schulden dem
Finanzminister ist es natürlich völlig
klar auch deshalb hat er heute eine Art
Titanic Alarm vor der Zeit gewarnt wenn
die corona-kredite zurückgezahlt werden
müssen und das Bundeswehr Vermögen
Sondervermögen aufgebraucht ist er
meinte wir steuern auf einen Eisberg zu
er sogar auf einen Eisberg fällt da
wurde dann der Schleier einmal
kurzzeitig sehr zu durchlässig danke
schön für diese Einschätzung aus berlin-
auf der Agenda der Bundesregierung steht
auch die Verkehrswende weniger Auto mehr
Fahrradbus und Bahn doch der Trend sieht
anders aus in Deutschland gibt es so
viele Autos wie nie
48,8 Millionen zählt das Statistische
Bundesamt das entspricht 583 PKW je 1000
Einwohner allerdings ist die autodichte
auf dem Land deutlich höher als in
Großstädten mit gutem ÖPNV um
alternative Verkehrskonzepte und neueste
Entwicklungen geht es auch auf der IAA
in München die heute der Bundeskanzler
eröffnete Peter Aumeier und Alexander
Pohl
bei seinem Rundgang über die Messe
appelliert Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz an
die deutschen Autohersteller billigere
Elektroautos anzubieten die Regierung
will dafür beim Ausbau der
lade-infrastruktur helfen wir werden als
erstes Land in Europa in den nächsten
Wochen ein Gesetz auf den Weg bringen
mit mit denen die Betreiber von fast
allen Tankstellen dazu verpflichtet
werden schnell Lademöglichkeiten mit
mindestens 150 Kilowatt für E-Autos
bereitzustellen Elektroautos sie sind
das Thema der diesjährigen IAA im August
wurden in Deutschland
86.649 reine E-Autos zugelassen ein Plus
von über 170% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
ob die Verkaufszahlen so bleiben scheint
unklar denn die Bundesregierung hat die
Förderung von elektrodienst wegen
eingestellt für die deutschen Hersteller
kommt hinzu die Chinesen bieten ihre
Elektroautos künftig weit günstiger an
den Gegnern der IAA geht es heute um
mehr als nur einen anderen Antrieb was
ich wirklich ändern muss ist der Kern
der Autoindustrie weil die setzt immer
noch auf zu viele zu schwere und zu
große Autos auch der Bundeskanzler
schwört die Versammelten Autohersteller
auf die neue Zeit ein die
mobilitätswende ist eine große Aufgabe
aber sie ist eine Teamaufgabe und ich
komme heute hier zu ihnen als
überzeugtes Mitglied dieses Teams
klimaneutrale Mobilität in Deutschland
und aus Deutschland sechs Tage lang
dauert die IAA mobility in München die
Veranstalter rechnen mit bis zu 700.000
Besucher
die KZ-Gedenkstätte Dachau lehnt einen
Besuch des freie wählerchef Hubert
Aiwanger ab zur Begründung hieß es
öffentlichkeitswirksame politische
Besuche im Vorfeld der bayerischen
Landtagswahl sind nicht erwünscht der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung hatte Aiwanger als
Zeichen der Solidarität einen Besuch in
Dachau nahegelegt Bayerns Vize
regierungschefs-
jetzt kaufen später bezahlen klingt
verlockend ist aber nicht ohne Risiko in
Deutschland schließen immer mehr
Verbraucher Ratenkredite ab die Zahl ist
rasant gestiegen laut Schufa gab es im
vergangenen Jahr gut 9,1 Millionen neue
ratenkreditverträge 30% mehr als im
Vorjahr beliebt sind vor allem Kredite
unter 1000 Euro doch auch die können
einem bei steigenden Zinsen schnell über
den Kopf wachsen warnt die Schufa
ein Sommer der extreme nach Spanien
kämpft jetzt auch Griechenland mit
Unwettern und Wassermassen wo neulich
noch Wälder brannten verwandeln sich
jetzt Bäche in reißende Flüsse der
Deutsche Wetterdienst waren dass die
Regenmenge um ein Vielfaches höher
werden könne als bei der Flutkatastrophe
im Ahrtal Volker
ohne Pause schon den zweiten Tag in
Folge in der 86.000 Einwohner Stadt
kommt so viel Wasser runter wie sonst im
ganzen Jahr und diese Massen schieben
die Fahrzeuge Weg wie Spielzeugautos der
Bürgermeister der Hafenstadt läuft durch
die Straßen und appelliert an die
Einwohner zu Hause zu bleiben
ich bitte alle inständig schauen Sie was
hier passiert gucken Sie sich das Wasser
an wie hoch ist
so eine Nacht haben die Menschen in
Zentral Griechenland schon seit Jahren
nicht mehr erlebt in den Städten Larissa
und Volos zählen die Feuerwehren mehr
als 12.000 Blitze in nur zwei Stunden
manche ortsbrechen die Fahrzeuge ein
weil die Wassermassen Straßen
unterspülen die Flüsse Schwellen mächtig
an viele Brücken werden dem Druck nicht
mehr lange standhalten denn es regnet
immer weiter
dramatische Wetterereignisse die
abzusehen waren das Mittelmeer ist enorm
aufgeheizt und dieses Wasser ist der
Zündstoff der Treibstoff für solche
Wetter also für heftige Gewitter die
sich ja jetzt dort entladen und
insgesamt sind diese Gewitter in einem
tief eingebettet und entladen sich
permanente also hier sind sehr große
Regenmengen zu erwarten schwere Unwetter
auch in der Küstenstadt Agios Johannes
die Behörden haben viele Orts auch auf
den Sporaden Inseln Fahrverbote für
Autos verhängt viele im Land sprechen
von einer Katastrophe erst die
verheerenden Brände juli und die
Überschwemmung
ist vor Ort Annette wie ist die Lage und
was Kommt da noch auf die Menschen zu
ja also so wie es jetzt momentan schon
seit Stunden und vor allen Dingen in den
Bergen war das 600 Liter bis zu 600
Liter pro Quadratmeter und dieses Wasser
fließt jetzt ab übersprüht die Straßen
wie hier hinter mir und auch in der
Stadt sieht es entsprechend aus gerade
von einer Minute bekam ich wieder in
warenanruf auf mein Handy waren SMS auf
mein Handy geschickt der
Katastrophenschutz hat nämlich für heute
Nacht eine Ausgangssperre verhängt auf
die wurde wieder erneut erinnert ab
morgen soll es dann noch schlimmer
werden es soll noch mehr regnen und äh
die Touristen die hier im Ort sind die
denn das ist ihre eine von Touristen
sehr beliebte Gegend sind bereits aus
dem Hotels evakuiert worden es gab
Stromausfälle
das ist davon auszugehen dass mindestens
zwei Tage weiter geht die Auswirkungen
davon sind noch gar nicht abzusehen
danke schön Annette hilsenbeck live aus
dem Unwettergebiet in Griechenland
zum Krieg in der Ukraine dort kämpfen
beide Seiten Russen und Ukraine auch mit
der hochumstrittenen Streumunition im
vergangenen Jahr sind dabei 890 Menschen
verletzt oder getötet worden meldet die
Beobachtungsstelle für Streumunition in
Genf zum aktuellen Kriegsverlauf bleibt
die Informationslage weiter unklar bei
einem Besuch in der Region saporicia
ehrte der ukrainische Präsident selenski
Soldaten nahe der Front angeblich für
eine gelungene Offensive Russland
dagegen bezeichnet die ukrainischen
Vorstöße im Osten und Süden weiter als
erfolglos
man kann nur ahnen was es bedeutet an
dieser Front zu kämpfen über den Versuch
die Soldaten zumindest für einen Moment
zu entspannen und auf andere Gedanken zu
bringen berichtet Hannah Hebestreit
es ist eine Pause vom Krieg irgendwo in
den Wäldern dicht an der Front die Musik
erinnert sie an ein Leben weit weg von
Explosionen Tod oder Kugelhagel es geht
um Gefühle um Liebe
Miroslav war bekannter reggae-interpret
in der Ukraine jetzt kämpfte er in einer
kultureinheit gegen Traumata
[Musik]
Soldaten fällt es schwer Zivilisten zu
vertrauen jetzt sind wir Waffenbrüder so
erreicht man diese Leute leichter
wer hier sitzt hat in den letzten
Monaten Kameraden verloren hat gekämpft
vielleicht getötet das hinterlässt
Spuren in der Seele auch wenn der Körper
intakt ist
gestern haben viele noch feindliche
Schützengräben oder Bunker gestürmt
jetzt sind Sie hier um abzuschalten man
spürt dass sie gerade noch schlimmes
durchgemacht haben
davon sollen sie sich hier erholen
körperlich und vor allem emotional
die Soldaten sind müde nicht kriegsmüde
sondern müde vom warten dass auch ihnen
die Stunde schlägt
seine Truppe ist psychologische
Ersthilfe solange der Krieg tobt ist
Kultur ein kleiner Trost
die Vereinten Nationen schlagen Alarm in
Afghanistan muss das
Welternährungsprogramm seine Hilfen
weiter kürzen der UN-Organisation fehlen
die Mittel Nothilfe sollen in dem Land
künftig nur noch drei Millionen Menschen
bekommen von insgesamt 15 Millionen die
nicht genug zu essen haben zu befürchten
sei dass es immer mehr unterernährte
Kinder gäbe seit der erneuten
Machtübernahme der islamistischen
Taliban vor zwei Jahren ist Afghanistan
vom Rest der Welt isoliert
was muss geschehen damit Afrika den
Klimawandel besser schultern kann darum
geht seit gestern bei einem Gipfel in
Kenias Hauptstadt Nairobi der Kontinent
ist derzeit für weniger als 10% der
globalen Treibhausgasemissionen
verantwortlich und doch Treffen in die
Folgen besonders hart etwa im
vergangenen Jahr extreme Hitze und
Brände im Norden außergewöhnliche Dürre
im Osten und tropische Wirbelstürme im
Süden insgesamt 110 Millionen Betroffene
Susann von Lojewski über afrikanische
Pläne und Forderungen
365 Windräder ragen in den Himmel von
Turkana die Region im Norden Kenias hat
nicht viel zu bieten doch der Windpark
von Turkana deckt 15 Prozent des
genianischen Energiebedarfs die Anlage
wurde mitten ins Nirgendwo gebaut
Anteilseigner sind europäische
Investoren und Regierungen die Firma
könnte noch viel mehr Strom erzeugen das
Problem ist die Logistik
die größte logistische Herausforderung
und die andere ist die fehlende
Infrastruktur als wir hierher gekommen
sind und auch Strom ist ein Problem
tatsächlich kommt das Stromnetz in
weiten Teilen Afrikas nicht hinterher
immer öfter kommt es zu landesweiten
Ausfällen es sind diese
Herausforderungen die auf dem ersten
klima-gipfel Afrikas im Mittelpunkt
stehen denn Energie hat für Afrika
weitreichende Folgen das bedeutet ob
Kinder nach lesen können um zu studieren
für ihre Schule das bedeutet ob sie mit
weniger Luftverschmutzung mit saubere
Autos und und Mobilität in der Schule
oder zu zur Arbeit kommen das geht um
Entwicklung
Entwicklung die in vielen Dörfern
Afrikas erst gar nicht ankommt dabei
könnten gerade erneuerbare Energien die
Menschen voranbringen
600 Millionen Menschen haben noch immer
keinen Zugang zu einfachster
Elektrizität wir möchten einen massiven
Ausbau erneuerbarer Energien die auf den
letzten und die letzte erreicht
Afrika will vor allem eines die
Ressourcen für die eigene Bevölkerung
nutzen
erst saßen sie wegen Regen und
matschfest jetzt wollen alle
gleichzeitig nach Hause vom Burning Man
Festival in der Wüste des
US-Bundesstaats Nevada kaum hatten die
Behörden gestern die Zufahrt wieder
freigegeben machten sich viele der knapp
70.000 Festivalbesucher auf den Heimweg
nach heftigen Regenfällen war das
Gelände übers Wochenende gesperrt worden
jetzt zum Tennis Krimi heute Nacht bei
den US Open New York Achtelfinale
5 Stunden 5 Sätze die beiden Spielern
alles abverlangten und am Ende
triumphierte Alexander
es mag an das Bild des Malers Edward
Monk erinnern nur dass sich der Schrei
von Alexander Zverev aus purer Freude
löst um ehrlich zu sein dass hier ist
einer der besten Momente in meiner
Karriere
sowohl Jannik Sinner als auch Alexander
Zverev müssen in dieser schwule New
Yorker Nacht bis an ihre körperlichen
Grenzen gehen viele Ballwechsel sind
auch am frühen Morgen immer noch hart
und kämpft einziger Wermutstropfen dass
ein Zuschauer den Text der ersten
Strophe des Deutschlandlied
fängt dann die hitlerhunde zu singen und
ein bisschen viel zu viel ist gut der
Betroffene wird aus dem Stadion geführt
und kann deshalb den matchballon nicht
mehr miterleben der Hamburger steht
damit zum dritten Mal nacheinander im
Viertelfinale der US Open und kann nun
gegen den Titelverteidiger Carlos
eigentlich nur noch gewinnen
[Applaus]
der spanische Fußballverband trennt sich
von
frauenweltmeistertrainer
Hintergrund will da hatte sich zunächst
hinter dem von der FIFA wegen des
kuss-skandals suspendierten Verbands
gestellt war aber auch schon zuvor von
Spielerinnen wegen seiner Arbeitsweise
heftig kritisiert worden
Samstag Festspiel der DFB elf in
Wolfsburg gegen Japan heute erstes
Training mit dem nachnominierten Thomas
Müller der den angeschlagenen Niklas
Füllkrug ersetzen könnte heute nur
Trainingsgast Niklaus Füllkrug wird
wegen einer Verletzung im linken
Oberschenkel beide Spiele verpassen der
Ausfall erhöht die Einsatzchancen von
Thomas Müller der nach neun Monaten
Pause zurückgekehrt ist vor dem
wegweisenden Duellen in denen es auch um
die Zukunft des Bundestrainers geht ist
allen die kritische Lage bewusst wir
wissen ganz genau wie viel auf dem Spiel
steht wir stehen auch beim beim Trainer
so ein bisschen in der Schuld weil wir
diejenigen sind die auf dem Platz gehen
und äh und die Resultate erziehen müssen
und das wollen wir jetzt unbedingt
machen Pascal groß vom englischen
Erstligisten brighton ist ein
kampfstarker Mittelfeldspieler der dem
verunsicherten Team neue Impulse geben
soll
ja da sind wir gespannt auf neue und
alte Gesichter ja vielen Dank
extreme Regenfälle in Griechenland und
strahlendes Spätsommerwetter in
Mitteleuropa wie das zusammenhängt und
wie es weitergeht erzählt gleich Katja
Hornbach das heute journal mit Maria
Slomka und viertel vor zehn hier
übernimmt morgen Jana pareises einen
schönen Abend ihnen noch und auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend eine der Kehrseiten unseres
sonnigen spätsommerwetterzieren
Mitteleuropa ist dieses Tief hier das
stabilisiert das hoch bringt aber enorme
Regenmengen mit in Griechenland hat es
zum Teil schon hunderte Liter Regen pro
Quadratmeter gegeben und es regnet dort
weiter denn dieses Tief regeneriert sich
über dem zum Teil 30 Grad warm
Mittelmeerwasser einfach weiter ganz
anders sieht das Wetter bei uns aus
heute Nacht ist es meist klar selten
bildet sich etwas Nebel die Temperaturen
sinken auf Werte von 16 bis 7 Grad jetzt
im September ist der Temperatur Tages
Gang interessant das schauen wir uns am
Beispiel von Hannover an in den nächsten
Stunden wird erstmal kälter die tiefsten
Temperaturen werden kurz nach
Sonnenaufgang erreicht das sind morgen
in Hannover so um die 14 Grad und dann
schwingen sich die Werte bis auf 30 Grad
drauf die werden gegen 17 Uhr erreicht
sonst liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen deutschlandweit
zwischen 25 Grad auf Rügen und 32 Grad
am Niederrhein und auch morgen sehr viel
Sonnenschein nur ein leichten gut aus
östlichen Richtungen und kaum mal
irgendwo ein Wolkenfeld und mit diesem
Wetter geht es in den nächsten Tagen
einfach so weiter bei 26 bis 32 Grad
guten Abend